hey youtubers it's Charlie I hope you
all had a chance to see Game of Thrones
season 4 episode 1 it was so much fun so
in my review video I asked you to submit
all your questions about the episode and
season 4 so I picked 10 of them to
answer in this video with one bonus
question but first things first
congratulations to Anna East you're the
winner of round one of my Game of
Thrones giveaway I'm doing a weekly
giveaway each week just to say thank you
to all you guys for being so awesome so
you win a $20 Amazon gift card I'll be
reaching out to you on your channel for
details round 2 of the giveaway will
begin on Sunday whenever I post my
episode two of you remember all you have
to do to participate is be a subscriber
and leave a comment and be nice so let's
answer some questions careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet also during question number 5 I
talked a lot about Jon Snow's you know
supposedly and father even though we
don't explicitly know who his parents
are if you just want to skip past that I
have a giant spoiler warning so you can
just skip forward in the video whenever
I tell you to so here we go question
number 1 Cletus Van Damme asks are there
any references to the fens being
cannibals in the books so it's actually
the SKA ghost tribe in the books that
are the cannibals but just like a lot of
things they fold those characters into
the Thesz just because they don't want
to cast like hundreds and hundreds of
people in the show
remember when Jon Snow was telling the
Nights Watch council about the wildling
army it's a hundred thousand strong so
there's no way they were going to be
able to portray all those people if they
do show us the army itself this season
they're probably gonna use a lot of CG
crowd duplication because a hundred
thousand people there's no way they're
gonna cast all those extras question
number two rayray asks based on this
episode how well do you think that
they're gonna stick to the book so DB
Weiss and David Benioff are really
committed to honoring the original text
so they do their best to hit all the big
signposts but ya little things will be
changed for anyone who's read the books
you know all the biggest stuff will
always be there it's just the small of
things that they have to combine or omit
altogether you know let the sir Dontos
seem you know in the books it was a
hairnet but on the show it was a
necklace that's a very minor change and
like Arya with the Hound you know who
knows what's gonna happen with that and
one of the trailers we saw her in the
middle of a training montage with needle
that's probably from the first couple of
episodes so I don't think they're
totally gonna change her story from the
books but
you know there will always be the Shay
exceptions when I say Shay exceptions
you know sometimes if they feel like a
character works really really well with
the other characters in the show they
might change their story just a little
bit to feature them more so there's not
a lot of Shay in the books but there's a
ton of her on the show so they might do
that with the Hound an aria but we'll
have to see question number three
vegetables if the Dragons keep growing
could they get as big as Smaug from The
Hobbit so I saw a fictional dragon size
chart and you know spouts from The
Hobbit is basically about the size of an
apartment complex the biggest dragon in
the history of Westeros was balerion the
black dread Aegon the conquerors dragon
there are a lot of things about Daenerys
and her three dragons that mirror Aegon
and his two sisters and their three
dragons for instance there are three
dragons were the same colors as Daenerys
so I think George are Martin is implying
that drogon will be just like balerion
he's still very young though Valyrian
lived to about 200 years old and
remember he had no natural predators so
it's possible that you know if the
dragons are unchallenged they have an
unlimited food supply and they're not
kept you know in captivity they could
just keep growing it's just a function
of you know food supply age and you know
open space to actually physically grow
question number four
Stephen Herman asks do you like how they
changed Arya and the Hound from the book
actually I do like it they're one of the
best pairs in the show so the longer
they stay together the better I think
it's hard to tell if they'll stay
completely faithful to the books but
until we see otherwise let's just assume
that the biggest events will still
happen the way they're supposed to
I guess if they ended up doing something
radically different from the books
it wouldn't be terrible the writing is
great the actors are great so no matter
what I'm gonna keep watching so if they
do change things completely you know I'm
not gonna flip out and stop watching so
here's that question number 5 where I
talk about Jon Snow's mother if you
don't want to know anything about the
theory or the evidence behind it just
skip forward in the video about one
minute so here we go number five all the
worlds the stage actually pointed
something out whenever Joffrey's
flipping through the white book there's
a page for Gerold Hightower he used to
be the commander of the Kingsguard
whenever Rhaegar Targaryen was still
alive so there's something on that page
that has to do with Lyanna Stark before
he died King Aerys set Hightower in a
couple of his men to find
Raigarh whenever he ran off with Lyanna
stark they found them at the Tower of
joy in the north part of Dorne
Rhaegar left to lead King Aerys army
against Robert's rebellion and made
Hightower stay behind to guard Liana
eventually Eddard Stark found them and
ended up killing Hightower and his men
when they found Liana
she was actually lying in a bed of blood
so this is where all the Jon Snow
theories come from because why else
would you find a woman lying in a bed of
blood you know unless she got stabbed
the implication is is that when
Hightower found Rhaegar and Lyanna she
was pregnant so Rhaegar asked Hightower
to stay in garter she died as a result
of childbirth and Eddard Stark got there
just as Jon Snow is being born so then
the theory continues that Eddard Stark
took Jon Snow and passed him off as his
own bastard because he really was the
son of Ice and Fire
but Oberyn Martell story that he told to
Tyrion kind of corroborates some of
these elements so there is a lot of
basis in historical fact for this theory
question number six
no Sherlock asks are we gonna see any
other Martel's in the season so there's
not a lot of Dorne is a geographical
location in book three so we might not
see a lot of Dorne until next season
think of it in terms of Daenerys journey
to different cities in the east you know
each season she goes to more and more
places so eventually we will see plenty
of Dorne you know it's really different
from the rest of Westeros so I can't
wait there's also a whole bunch of
really awesome characters that come from
Dorne that hopefully we'll get to see in
season five question number seven Hyrule
Savior asks is Oberyn Daenerys uncle no
Daenerys is actually the youngest child
of King Aerys and his wife was another
Targaryen remember all the sister wives
they were famous for she's essentially
first cousins with the Martel's Prince
Durant's sister was Elia who married
Rhaegar and Oberon is Duran's younger
brother question number 8 Jessie wait
asks do you feel that Arya is maturing
as a character in much the same way as
Caryl in The Walking Dead yes but their
characters are kind of headed in
opposite directions they're both at the
crossroads so to speak you know
appropriate since Arya was literally
just at the crossroads Karl's trying to
decide whether or not he's becoming a
monster and he doesn't want to be you
know he wants to stay a good person re
on the other hand is embracing the dark
path she's on you know she's turning
into a killer and she's really enjoying
that because for her it means the path
to revenge
question number nine Dex asks which
character in the story are you most
excited to see this season so in no
particular order
Tyrion Lannister Jon Snow and Arya Stark
it's really hard to pin down just one
character I feel like there are so many
that have such interesting changes going
on to this season that it's gonna be a
lot of fun for everyone
question number 10 sudonym asks episode
two the rose and the lion sounds like
the purple wedding is that true yes we
saw all those wedding scenes in the
trailer for episode 2 so we're gonna see
the wedding and the banquet whenever
they were filming they said it was the
biggest shoot since the season 1
premiere at least in terms of number of
people on the set those days Charles
Vance who plays Tywin Lannister said
that it was so big that it felt like a
short film in and of itself you know the
wedding and the banquet
so one last bonus question silver blaze
miss asks how about the sir Duncan the
tall shout out yeah that was really cool
it was in the white book whenever
Joffrey was flipping pages he gives a
shout out to sir Duncan the tall
that's from the Duncan egg spin-off
books that George our Martin has been
writing it's also a comic book you
should actually read them if you haven't
they're really awesome and I actually
talk about them a bunch in the Game of
Thrones movie video I did a little while
ago I'll be sure to add a link to that
video at the end of this video but thank
you so much for sending your questions
this is gonna be so much fun this season
there's so much big stuff happening like
I said since it's really hard you know
to talk about things without talking
about spoilers I'll be sure to try and
provide clear warnings so that when we
do things like Jon Snow's mother you can
just skip ahead if you want to because a
lot of people just want to watch the
show and don't care about the books also
heads up because it was such an amazing
response to this past weekend I'm gonna
start doing Game of Thrones bonus videos
that are you know loosely related to the
episodes or topics that you guys suggest
on Sunday mornings just to get us you
know pumped up for each new episode you
can suggest topics for those videos in
the comments below in the meantime you
can click here to learn all about sir
Duncan the tall in that game of Thrones
movie video talked about and you can
click here to watch my review the
episode thank you so much for watching
there's gonna be so much fun this year
high fives
you